the amazing evolution of the Disney
Princess with 2016 s Moana joining the
lineup of Disney Princesses this key
figure has come a long way since 1937
Snow White hit the red button down below
to subscribe to our channel where it all
began in the beginning Snow White
encapsulated a good woman in the 1930s
she put up with a lot she did the
cleaning she waited passively for a man
to show up and rescue her and all the
while she happily and patiently sang she
was dainty and ladylike some critics
consider her the most anti feminist of
all the princesses Snow White in the
Seven Dwarves and the other classic
Disney Princess movies had a love story
at their heart and marriage was a
princess's goal much of the same
in the 1950s Cinderella and Aurora
followed Snow White
all three princesses were essentially
the same character just with different
hair and dress color they became a
stereotype of what Disney Princess
looked like and behaved like then-white
attractive women and they waited around
for their prince charming to save them
the villains were the same too the Evil
Queen wicked stepmother and Maleficent
good female characters were pitted
against bad ones independence creeps in
after Sleeping Beauty there was a
30-year gap until the Little Mermaid in
1989 this Renaissance era assured in a
new type of Disney Princess Ariel was
the first to be more independent and
progressive she went against her
father's wishes and was proactive in
seeking a new life I'll be a one focused
on finding a man similarly Belle in
1991's Beauty and the Beast was more
independent but still yearned for a love
story like her earlier counterparts
class Schiff in 1992 s Aladdin we
finally had a Disney princess who was a
bit more culturally diverse and who
broke away from the formula of a girl
meeting a prince Jasmine was the big
royal deal in this movie while Aladdin
was a street boy it was the first time a
Disney princess didn't marry a man who
was already a prince and the first time
one lived in a different culture but
critics had an issue with Jasmine's
seduction scenes and her Western
appearance more cultural diversity
Disney continued to release princess
films with heroines from other cultures
in 1995 it was Pocahontas and in 1998 it
was Mulan both of whom were the
eponymous lead characters in their
movies like Aladdin Pocahontas was
criticized for its portrayal of over
sexualized women and its representation
of colonialism Mulan was generally met
with positive responses to its depiction
of a princess who was strong determined
and a risk-taker but again the cultural
representation was troubling to some
critics with its negative presentation
of Chinese culture first
african-american princess it took more
than ten years for the Disney princess
to arrive but in 2009 at tiene burst
onto the scene in The Princess and the
Frog as the first of the new wave of
more feminist Disney Princesses the
film's depiction of another culture and
an independent woman received more
praise than the studio's previous
efforts
Chanos hard-working and did not rely on
a man moving forward and looking back
Rapunzel brought some sass to the line
of Disney Princesses entangled in 2010
from hitting Flynn with a frying pan de
scaping her towers she showed bravery
and was certainly strong-willed but
there was a certain amount of hearken
back to the old days she needed Flynn to
help her and when she married him a
brought the focus back to the love story
however unlike the first princesses she
was an entirely reliant on being saved
Rapunzel and Flynn saved each other
moving beyond marriage brave showed a
very different attitude towards marriage
than Disney's earlier Princess films in
the 2012 movie Morita had no interest in
finding love and in fact she was the
first Disney Princess to not have a love
interest without any songs have around
the stubborn and independent Morita is
about as far from Snow White as you can
get she rejected her mother's
expectations of how princess should look
and behave no wonder many feminists were
impressed
sisterly love the move away from
romantic love and brave was continued in
frozen sure the 2013 movie did have a
love interest in it but the main focus
of the film was the love between sisters
Anna and Elsa's relationship was what it
was all about and unlike the princesses
of the classic era these two didn't sit
around waiting for a man to rescue them
they rescued each other
girl power in 2016
Disney introduced a new princesses
thought to be the most progressive of
all Moana way leekie is Disney's first
Polynesian princess the daughter of a
chief she goes on a daring journey over
the ocean to help save her Island in the
same year Disney unveiled another new
princess this time on TV
Ellen of avalor features Disney's first
ever at Latina princess who is brave and
adventurous too and there's no Prince
Charming here either which is your
favorite Disney Princess let us know in
the comments below and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up